o psol decidiu lançar mais um vídeo e
hoje trouxe o procana uma coisa de
frente um desafio criativo em que vai
tentar fazer sim coisas minimamente o
deixa usando filipinas então diga nos
comentários qual foi um projeto que
vocês gostaram mais e que vocês fariam
se tivessem muitos filhos pneus e isso
agora usar por hora
[Música]
hum
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e prosseguiu no fim espero que vocês
tenham gostado deste vídeo assim um
pouco diferente de um documentário que
vocês forem conferir os pneus porque o
tanque bastante e tem que fazer alguma
coisa com elas para depois poder mandar
os particulares em porque estou para
muitos passa aqui no escritório tem
muito obrigado até a próxima